we will go next to our caller from the
let's go to 575 area code caller from
575 if you can hear me 575 tell me your
name where you're throwing from and
what's on your mind yeah my name is
Kevin Albers I'm calling from San Diego
California all right go ahead with your
question together okay so stefan
molyneux and other extreme libertarians
have the idea that government is all bad
because no entity should be allowed to
initiate force against another in a fair
society right believes did everything
would be best taken care of by a
completely free market once we give you
a rock operative government entirely so
assuming your society existed what do
you see is the biggest reason that a
free market driven no government Society
just wouldn't work well once you get
beyond so one of the big things that
separates humans from other animal
species is that there are animal species
that are able to work together in large
numbers towards a shared goal but not in
a flexible way right so animals look
that like for example ants would be an
example or bees they can work together
in really large groups to build their
ant farm or whatever you would call it
nest I don't know what the thing is
called right or beans good I'm sorry a
colony exactly or bees who can work but
they can only work together in really
specific ways they are not able to work
together in large numbers in anything
other than these instinctual ways and
then there are other other animal
species that can work together in more
flexible ways so for example we could
think of the great apes or whales for
example but they can't really work
together in large groups right so the
big distinguishing factor the reason
humans have been able to advance is
because we can work together in large
groups but also flexibly on making a
building or organizing a society or
government or creating airplanes or
whatever the case may be when you
eliminate that that by saying government
is oppression taxation is slavery
everyone just at every time needs to be
allowed to do whatever it is that they
want you cannot get the level of
progress that we have had
in a literal sense because you are
making it impossible to actually work
together in this way now the libertarian
will retort by saying no no David if the
free-market dictated that the best path
forward the most profitable path forward
was for humans to completely freely
choose to organize and work together on
some of the big projects that government
would otherwise do like road building or
whatever the case may be then they would
do it which then makes it a semantic
difference because you're effectively
forming a type of government and as soon
as one person doesn't want that then you
get back to the exact situation you're
in now yeah yeah that makes sense it
just seems like whenever you have a
free-market society they always talk
about how it would be perfect and
everything would be fantastic but we'll
ask them to give you an example of where
that's worked well it never worked but
that's the thing it's the same thing
with it with with no no there's no true
social and no true communism it's never
worked anywhere so you can never point
to an example of it and you know stefan
molyneux and all of these other people
would say like well they need to try it
because it's gonna be so great
yeah well check out by the way check out
our video check out our video Kevin
socialism has never worked it debunked
because it's not I have read that oh
yeah I have I have watch that okay yeah
all right good
all right Kevin thanks very much
appreciate the call yep thanks okay no
problem